coming in right now too big our guest in
Jim Norton and Sam Roberts here uh area
there she is Nancy Grace hello thank you
for being here Nancy welcome to Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts that would be I'm
Jim that's Jim Norton and I'm Sam
Roberts thanks yes he does
we're live how are you this morning yeah
you're right you're good I'm happy to be
here
you are yeah you're uh how do you feel
about leaving HLN cuz you've been there
for what 12 years yeah you know what
it's it's bittersweet I know that's a
cliche but it really is because um I
never dreamed growing up on a red dirt
road in the middle of nowhere some
people would say that I would ever have
a show on HLN so it was beyond anything
I'd ever really dreamed of did you yet
do they ask you to leave or did you want
to leave I wouldn't say that I wanted to
leave I felt like it was the right time
for me to leave because I'm leaving
behind a lot but I'm going to where I
want to go I had like I'll be honest I
had a problem with you for a long time
because I felt like you were
capitalizing on tragedies and I'm sure
you were accused of that before it we're
not were you capitalizing on this stuff
as a crime victim myself I guess it's
the way you look at the world
I invite crime victims on and tell
stories from their point of view I help
find missing people and help solve
unsolved homicides now from your point
of view you would say that any news
report say on Isis or the hurricane or a
car crash air crash victims is all
capitalizing on misery so that you're
singling out my shows interesting but I
I think inaccurate I would know I would
I know you mean but I wouldn't say that
just reporting on it because if it's
fair you have to do it
victim advocacy for victims is important
all that stuff is good what I'm saying
is things like the hashtags like tot mom
or
pot for tot or whatever those are those
are like those are beyond just hey I'm
reporting this I'm trying to get to the
bottom of it it's almost like I'm making
this kind of a catchy thing so people
associate me with it cuz hashtags cannot
be sentences and so I don't know if
you're familiar with digital media mm-hm
but is over a few words long right so
what I we tried to do is take a story
and I brought this really from my law
school days where I would have to
condense a very difficult and convoluted
case into something simple and did with
juries to break down complicated and
convoluted facts and give it to them one
two three that's how I look at cases I
usually come up with a moniker and for
whatever case it is it could be the
scenario it could be the defendant and
that's what I call it oh the army mom
oh the Ohio serial killer you know like
that that's how I identify cases could
you see that the like like hashtag baby
and dryer could be looked at as
trivializing something that would
otherwise be tragic yeah I hear what
you're saying right but you don't see it
that way no um and and the Duke we have
to ask you about the Duke rape case
because you you know look I underst I
thought those guys were probably guilty
too when I first saw it they didn't look
you didn't look good but then you you
went after them pretty hard and then
Mike Nifong got I guess he was just
barred and you didn't or did you come on
and clear it up and I just thought it
was well if you read the transcripts
before you ask me the question you would
know that there was no point that I ever
said these guys are guilty although it's
been commonly and very happily portrayed
that I did also when one of the accused
came forward and gave a statement and
spoke to the press and may have even
answer questions but when he spoke to
the press the camera came to me and I
said
that is the state's worst nightmare
because I think that guy's telling me
truth he looks like he's telling the
truth
now you left that out of your scenario
why aren't you completely understand I
asked you about I didn't leave it out
purposely I didn't know it's okay okay
well how about this you did get sued and
lose if you want to paint it that way
you say it anyways what didn't you lose
to a Michael Skakel for uh we'll have to
settle that um I can't give the result
but I would not consider that a loss but
it was settled mm-hmm by CNN yes okay
well then I have to ask you that I me
and I would like to point out that
Michael Skakel was found guilty of
murder by a jury yes he was and that on
our show a reporter said there was DNA
on the sing and the lawsuit was not
about whether he was guilty or innocent
it was about was their DNA no no I know
is not about his guilt or innocence
found guilty I know that murder of
Martha Moxley I know honestly is there
anything that you regret the way you did
cover like is there any like looking
back to you go you know what I was wrong
about that or I fought too hard on this
side and I ended up being wrong or I was
presenting all this evidence that didn't
actually fit the case at the end of the
day on television of course I'm talking
about no not that I know I've yet but I
haven't really had time to reflect back
on everything yeah you took a lot of
heat to for the report that you did on
remember when the Ultimate Warrior died
and you brought on DDP the wrestler and
you were talking about wrestlers dying
of steroids and drug overdoses and
things like that when steroids weren't
involved in the Ultimate Warrior's death
no they were not and on the people that
you listed you listed a whole bunch of
wrestlers that it died
before they were 40 and some of the
wrestlers that you listed one of them
had fallen from the ceiling one of them
had been shot like there were all these
guys all these names I don't think it
was ever said that those guys died from
steroid ever does no but you said that
there's a you said really do you
establish the untimely death but you
establish the argument that there's drug
abuse and steroids then you say here is
a list of wrestlers that died young and
so you didn't say that's why they died
really argument leave that professional
wrestlers are not protected I think that
everybody gets a big kick out of
watching them and whether the wrestling
is real or not people love watching it
and I think that those wrestlers those
women and men they go in the ring are
not protected I don't think anybody is
ever looking out for them and I think
that they're used badly so if that was
your intention and you know of course I
can believe you on that you're telling
me that what goes through your mind when
a lot of wrestlers see your report and
come back at you with venom saying
you're not representing us you're not
telling our story and this what you're
portraying isn't what's happening
because that's the way that I'm sorry
they feel that way most wrestlers
responded and that's I mean the
wrestlers that were on your show you
know Diamond Dallas Page who was on your
show was furious if I don't know if you
remember about I do remember about you
know coming on your show he said thought
came on on false pretences perfect
gentleman he could not have been nicer
and I don't want him to feel bad and I
feel bad that he feels bad but the fact
remains that in the wrestling industry
there is a very high occurrence of
untimely deaths for a lot of different
reasons and I feel that it's the
industry's fault I don't think these
guys and women but mostly guys are the
ones dying inordinately young I don't
think that they are told all the risks
of what they're getting into so when the
people of the year do you advocate for
when you're saying this like this is
your intention to advocate for these
people and the people that you're
advocating for come to you and say we
don't need you doing that for us we
don't like what you're doing don't do it
I've rarely had that happen it happened
in this case yes it did with that
wrestler he did not like the way and I
mean I went and most wrestlers that
watch that especially agree with you I
mean I talk to wrestlers all the time
you talk to wrestlers all the time and
you have taught to several wrestlers
that said that right but that does not
mean most wrestlers so that you have
taught some wrestlers that said that
right I hear you I respect that and I'm
sorry they feel that way I really don't
know what else you want me to say but
you know I don't like you met you
mentioned the news tie-in and I again
there's a there's a weird line with
public service and reporting something
and when it becomes hey this is the
thing that I can associate myself with
and you know you kind of denying that
fact okay let me just set it straight
right now I'm sorry that you guys
clearly don't like what I do I feel bad
about it so there you obviously don't
like me that's okay so I'm okay with my
show and I'm okay with representing
crime victims and it's like the two of
you were just so anxious to like throw a
shot at me that's okay so I'm done and
that is not why I shot you it's not as I
was saying a shot at you interrupted but
it's not what you're saying to be
inaccurate I'm not trying a shot at you
don't mind and I'm sorry the wrestlers
feel that way but the truth is that a
huge amount of wrestlers die at a young
age for a lot of different reasons and
that is what that screen was for now if
you or somebody else interpret it a
different way I feel bad about that so
no one's throwing a shot at you and
saying that okay don't worry about no
I'm not worried about saying one decent
question since I walked in here
everything you both have you have asked
has been an attack none of the time the
question the things that people see now
you can't now you're you so used to a
victim agamous Agassi advocacy I should
plug it advocate yours do you feel like
a victim because we're asking questions
you like a victim well we're not
attacking you we're not attacking and
they are okay and there are these
questions how people care
yeah I mean these are things that people
talk about and don't necessarily get the
chance to talk to you I'm sorry to say
they're not decent questions I don't
know if that's a wholly accurate like
they really care about that's not true
we're gonna I actually watch it I want
you I wash your clips last night
you're playing an attorney and I will
promote what you're here to probably
it's called hailey D mystery murder with
love and it premieres Sunday October the
23rd on Hall
mark at 9:00 p.m. I was a scene with you
play it's kind of like a Gloria Allred
type attorney it seems and it was good
what I saw was good I watched it last
night we only got three clips and that
was what I saw okay great thank you do
you welcome but I mean don't I feel like
a shot with anybody right on no there's
no parting shot yeah it's fair for
someone to say to you it is fair but it
would also be fair if you had a question
other than an attack but you know what
again
it's amazing are you seeing you no one
said you haven't to face worst and no
one is saying that you have any more
questions how do you justify a lot
latching on to all of these hashtags and
things without saying that you are
capitalizing on dead can you back to
your first question yes I would like my
honest answer as a prosecutor you should
artists and these are [ __ ] the
answer is my program is to help solve
unsolved homicides and find missing
people which we have done now if you
don't - if you don't like that and you
don't like the way I do it then don't
watch it I like the I like what the
answer you just gave I think your time
is up
bye-bye take care you can leave if you
want no we're not gonna kill ourselves
after the interview Thanks Thank You
Nancy for stopping by
I went better than I thought it would
miss any get to a side titty boy -
chainsaw Nancy Grace ladies gentlemen
you know a whole lot for the interview